all of a sudden they were everywhere
kids taking to the streets demanding
politicians to save the planet and their
future an international agreement struck
in Paris in 2015 was to be the decisive
step but it seems like people are
polluting more not less
the topic is urgent and has entered
campaigns for the EU elections in some
areas Europe is trying to be a
front-runner
it's banning single-use plastic
but what good is that when you look at
pictures like these
I see the passion and the will to change
the way we handle pollution and climate
change everywhere in Europe but is it
enough so I ask myself can Europe save
the planet
[Music]
in late winter and I looked out of my
office window in Brussels and saw this
15,000 students skipping school and
making a lot of noise for the climate
the next week I made sure to be down on
the streets with them their message was
clear movers planets my present way we
are very frustrated and something need
to change the leaders of Europe have
always seen themselves as global
frontrunners when it comes to fighting
climate change is the shortest Deezer
strategy offered Kinkaid the [ __ ]
ossifer Virgenes bastard armand de la
razón de serra la razón sebastian take
the school never good today Europe wants
to slash its carbon emissions by 40% in
the next 11 years but right now it looks
like no European country will meet this
goal
these students here have a pretty clear
opinion on that and one of them is
putting some Iike the sixteen year old
should be in school at this time of day
just like most of the others wedding
ready getting triple la talk of us
Calcasieu
Erica Cassell de Carla conditions
protests like these are taking place all
over the world so the awareness among
younger people is there and politicians
also seem devoted to doing something but
here's what's really happening
the Polish government wants to keep
logging one of the last remaining
primeval forests in Europe at the same
time every summer huge fires like this
one in Portugal are setting parts of
Europe ablaze some say they're fueled by
climate change
many countries like Germany still depend
on coal plants for electricity all of
that is bad news for the melting polar
icecaps and global warming in general
but how bad really there are a lot of
opinions out there especially on global
warming it's time to talk to someone who
deals in facts even if it means I need
to go back to school University to be
precise eating cough is a professor at
the University of Leuven close to
Brussels and an expert on climate policy
she's also very familiar with Europe's
goal to slash carbon emissions by 40%
Europe always pretends to be the
front-runner but are they really Europe
has done a lot and has been a leader in
the past and still is comparatively
ambitious but it still has to do a lot
and improve its efforts certainly in
areas such as transportation if we think
about the emissions from cars from
lorries and a number of other sources
there we're still increasing our
emissions and that is an area that has
been very difficult to tackle
we all remember diesel gate and many of
the scandals so that is an area where
many policy makers have done a lot but
still need to do much more so do you
feel like this is a hopeless case
I'm not that pessimistic there are many
signs that couldn't turn people
pessimistic but if we give up hope then
I guess we're yeah we're doomed there's
a lot of opportunity for generating not
only effects are good for the climate
and the environment but also good for
jobs for our economy for our exports and
those aspects so I think that's one area
where we have big chances or where we
have big opportunities but it's
difficult because we need to change
current mindsets current structures and
do you feel like yeah that message is
being heard by the by the right people
well the pupils on the street so really
now the next generation asking for it
and asking their parents to not leave a
world that's not livable anymore I think
that's that's the most hopeful sign that
we have at the moment ok so you don't
think 40% is too ambitious no I think we
need to be more ambitious to be honest I
thought I'd be a lot more depressed
after this chat with Katya even cope
usually when you talk to people who know
a lot of things about climate change
pollution and generally speaking the
state of the planet they tend to be
rather pessimistic now this was
different
Katya Beadon cope seemed rather
optimistic especially regarding the role
of Europe so this is definitely
something that the kids demonstrating in
Belgium would have liked to hear
yes enthusiasm is in large supply at the
climate protests but do the young people
actually have a plan other than taking
to the streets
no conversation was about the potential
solutions because in the kinetically
governor Memphis assisted a family
basketball interpreted good dose and
Fahim is silicon among affair of
beaucoup de mon Soho Grigio CSV we were
to steal the mod no camera we see the
whole town will see people in your band
come sir please please don't do so
Capriccio had a pact it really shows you
shortly
the students are competing with powerful
lobbies that have no interest in
tightening co2 rules but the figurehead
of the movement create a tune bag has
managed to put climate change on the
agenda just in time for the European
elections at the EU Parliament she
brought her cause to the politicians
directly I expect them to to take action
now because there's not much time we
still have an open window that is not
going to be over too long in which we
can act so we need to take that
opportunity to to do something and they
should so what are the European
politicians that are supposed to really
do something prepared to actually do I
asked some of them whether they are
hearing the movements demands of course
I am
I'm very proud of that generation I
think they are doing something important
and I think they are strong and they
demand something from politics and I'm
ready to tackle that responsibility and
I want my colleagues here to listen to
yes definitely and I think it's very
important that young people engage and
it's a real important subject and I very
much like this movement what exactly are
you ready to do one of my strong
the mounds on this house is that we
should respect the Paris agreement for
me it was very important that in the
plenary in March we adopted a resolution
where we support the target of net
climate neutrality we need to have at
least 55% reduction on co2 until 2030 in
2050 the European Union should not emit
more then for example our forests absorb
or modern technology could take out of
the atmosphere we need to act every day
to improve climate politics in the EU
and that is my role to make sure that
the kids who demands more will feel that
that is implemented it may be not enough
what we are doing but without Europe we
would be hopeless and that's why we
shouldn't criticize the European Union
for not doing anything we should
motivate Europe to do more much more say
the climate activists but is the noise
they make going to be enough to compete
with lobbyists that try to influence
politicians across Europe I want to be
as enthusiastic as these kids and
believe that humanity can still turn
things around
but maybe
too old for that because from experience
I know that if humans find a way to
enrich themselves they will do it no
matter the cost to others or the planet
so it's pretty clear that kids here are
fed up and want to take matters into
their own hands but there are some good
examples what can be done to save the
planet
and one of those good examples takes us
here recognize it beautiful coastlines
[Music]
nice pugs
friendly people a charming capital
[Music]
and mountains of plastic yes the
European Union has taken up the fight
against plastic waste and that brings us
to this place it's in Ireland actually
in Dublin and according to some
statistics the Irish produce the most
plastic waste per capita in the European
Union that is of course and see these
little plastic items straws cigarette
butts throwaway plates and cups and
short single-use plastic is supposed to
disappear from Europe by 2021 the
European Parliament approved the ban in
March 2019 it's one of the first pieces
of legislation worldwide trying to get
rid of throw away plastic which brings
us back to Ireland I want to find out
whether this kind of law
to make an impact but plastic is a
complex matter as I'm soon to find out
Liam done knows a thing or two about
plastic he runs this recycling facility
on the outskirts of Dublin and when he
gets started on the different kinds of
plastic you need to hold on tight many
countries have a popular turn scheme for
these buffets we don't our customers put
them in the household green bin and we
use an optical separator to recover them
so clear green blue coke Volvic seven
off all the mineral drinks are all mixed
together we make one single grade of PE
tea and then the last optical separator
recovers all other types of plastics so
your polystyrene your low-grade a
mushroom trays those blue trays food
trays and the microwavable dinners and
your coffee cup lids polystyrene
ok I get it the plastic business is very
complicated in fact it really is a
pretty big business that's a lot of
plastic and this plastic is worth a lot
of money so this is the stuff that you
can sell for the highest price yes this
is our HDPE natural and it's 2% of the
content of the household recycling bin
and yes at today's prices that's March
2019 it's worth about 300 to 350 years a
ton what's much more difficult to
recycle are these the crinkly type
plastics and foil plastics from your
perspective who's know so much about
plastic and quite honestly I have
trouble falling sometimes but what needs
to happen to get this problem under
control and I think the number of types
of plastic needs to be reduced the
number of composite packages so even for
example having a plastic package that
has a big paper label on it that makes
it far far more difficult to recycle so
maybe through legislation or through
collaborating between the product
producers and the packaging
manufacturers and the retailers that
maybe we could single-stream our plastic
so if you only had PE tea or only had
LDPE and it motors that are easily
recycle easy recyclable and also
indicate whether or not they can or
can't be recycled on the labeling make
the labeling much much more clearer for
the householder because people genuinely
do have an issue particularly with the
soft plastics but it appears that some
people don't have an issue with throwing
those plastics anywhere except the trash
Dublin isn't an exceptionally dirty city
but given that according to some studies
the amount of plastic waste per capita
is higher here than anywhere else in the
EU some of it ends up in the parts and
waterways of the Irish capital the
situation has gotten worse ever since
China stopped buying the world's plastic
waste at the beginning of 2018 like
others Ireland is now stuck with its own
discarded plastics some folks around
here are trying to do something about it
they are literally taking the litter or
matters into their own hands enter Lynda
Leonard as often as she can she roams
the streets of Dublin her normal job is
working for a travel company that
company wants to make sure the city is
as clean as possible and also earn
certain eco certifications along the way
so they organize so-called litter picks
with the Green Team of the company the
hardest part are the plastic filled
cigarette butts
they're so small like you don't feel
you've made as big an impact when your
bag is not going to be very full but
it's gonna take much time to fit more
time to fill the bag to pick up these
little cigarette butts and because I
don't smoke when they're carcinogenic
and they're bad for people I can't see
any advantage with a cigarette cigarette
butts are also part of the new EU
legislation one filter takes up to 12
years to disintegrate so the EU wants to
hold tobacco companies accountable for
the cleanup of the stubs for the litter
pickers that's good news but it's not
enough not just the cigarette companies
the beer companies all the companies
that are producing this way so I think
you can change people's behavior with
taxation and make it more into the
consciousness as well because Ireland is
known for its greenness and if you just
continue to just import trash into it
it's not going to say nice and green and
be a place where we want to live or to
welcome our tourists here after one hour
the group has made quite a haul
so I know Lynda Leonard and her
colleagues are making an impact albeit
small if everybody did that the world
would be a different place but the truth
is very few people engage in such a way
I'm not doing it either do the activists
really think things can still be turned
around in Europe so we have European
elections coming up in May what would
you expect the new European Parliament
to do Vanson single-use plastic and
enact bail fur deposit refund scheme for
plastic bottles okay well if you had
your wildest dreams come true what
should they do and tax the companies
that are causing the waste and make us
that they're aware of their impact on
the environment and do you ever lose
hope you know you go there a day after
day you collect the litter of the
rubbish and it seems to never get less
well if more people become conscious
with it
become less and if the policy is enacted
as promised and it's pity it's not
sooner that's all but do you think the
people's minds are changing too or just
legislation absolutely and well once we
become more visible so yes definitely
there's a shift in mindset you can you
can tell around you that this is
happening absolutely if you look at my
colleagues here and all the work we've
put in today you can see it's a visible
positive action I guess you need to be
an optimist when you're in the business
of saving the planet that's increasingly
difficult when it comes to the seeds
Ireland has thousands of kilometres
worth of coastline so the country isn't
just dealing with its own plastic the
stuff washes up from all across the
globe even if you can't see it plastic
is everywhere especially micro plastic
it's even been found in human well not
good there's so much of it in the oceans
that one report estimates there will be
more plastic than fish in the oceans by
2050 including those tiny particles
called micro plastic already plastic is
entering the food chain marine animals
eat it this way it will have more than
40 kilograms of plastic in its stomach
the problem of course is not just with
huge whales it affects fish living in
the Irish Sea as well but these are in
an aquarium right next to the beach in
the town of brain
[Music]
when you look at these bottom-dwelling
creatures and you see how they naturally
feed it doesn't take a genius to work
out how much of these broken-down
plastics they're actually ingesting
consider rays and sharks they have been
around for millions they actually
predate dinosaurs and and raised
themselves been around for 170 million
years so there are the the art survivors
and they have survived everything that
we've managed to throw at them over the
centuries and yet this product plastic
is starting to have an impact and it's
starting to undermine their survivor
abilities to be honest or - I try and
stay focused on the positive and the
things that we can do in order to to
make a better environment because to
dwell on what's going wrong it's just
it's just it's very depressing to be
honest with you yep
older guys like us tend to be
pessimistic but it's no use being all
spineless about it the threat is real
and can be found right next to the
aquarium a seemingly spotless beach on
the surface
but underneath the rocks it's a
different story
small pieces of plastic okay it's
nothing like some beaches in Asia
china produces roughly a third of the
world's mismanaged plastic waste but
oceans have no borders so what good is a
law against single-use plastics in
Europe the plastic from all over the
world can wash up here it all helps and
you have to start somewhere and to
address the issue on our own fronts that
is is the first step then it is a
question of applying pressure to
whatever political diplomatic channels
are necessary to influence the change in
in Asia are you hopeful for that long
term it's it's difficult to say it will
happen but whether it happens before
that before the critical point of no
return that's that's what some say you
don't think we're there yet at that
point no no I don't think we're there
yet I think we're we're very close but I
don't think we're there yet it's a point
of no return I don't think right apart
to no return I think I think there is
still hope
I think humanity still has the ability
to pull itself out of this awful mess
that we've done we've blindfolded you
know can't blindly walked ourselves into
there are signs everywhere in Europe
that people are trying to do just that
from climate change to the avalanche of
plastic on land and in the seas
it seems that Europeans are much more
aware of what they're doing to their
home than in the past but is it going to
be too little too late and the consensus
I found is that the European Union is
moving in the right direction for
example with the new legislation on the
ban of single-use plastic but that it's
not nearly enough so the next European
Parliament will have to do more much
more if it wants to contribute to saving
this planet
[Music]
you